welcome to database def talk I'm your
host in-house Kazi our today's guest is
Mikkel tuna bark McHale is the founder
and CEO of super matrix super matrix is
a tool that faces marketing data into
Google Data studio and other platforms
[Applause]
okay welcome to the show thank you great
to be here so super matrix and Google
Analytics and it's developer relations
team have a long history and I've heard
that there was also a t-shirt involved
somewhere there can you tell our
audience about that in our story
sure several years ago I was working at
the marketing department of a gaming
company and my job there was through to
reporting on our marketing activities
but a large part of my time went into
copy pasting numbers from Google
Analytics and other sources into Excel
and that was really time-consuming and
boring so when the Google Analytics API
came out I figured I could use that to
automate that process and I did some
googling around the issue and I found a
forum post by nick mihailovski with no
data studio p.m. saying that the first
person who integrates their Google
Analytics API with excel gets a free
Google t-shirt and I figured that's
perfect I get to solve my own problem
and I also get a free t-shirt so but it
was more script that sauce that issue
and I shared that with Nick and Nick
sent that's good and he sent me the
t-shirt but even more importantly he
talked about my solution and that
generated a lot of interest and left me
to quit my job and the font for metrics
it's amazing in what areas does super
matrix help its customers and how right
so marketers they struggle with their
data being spread out in various
different systems so they may be doing
advertising on Google Facebook Twitter
Linkedin they have of analytics tools
such as Google Analytics they have CRM
various other systems where they have
their data and getting the full picture
is difficult many marketers they still
rely on a manual process of cutting this
data together so they may be doing copy
pasting into Excel work I was doing they
may be downloading CSVs and manually
merge
those together or they may have hacked
together some scripts that are
unreliable what we do is we automate
that process for them so we have built
high quality integrations to all of
these different advertising and
marketing tools and we get that data
together and put that data or make the
data available in the tools that
marketers generally want to use such as
Google sheets Google Data Studio
Excel and others how is super Wicked's
relevant for your customers to mention
that to domotics is pulling in data from
all these different sources and making
it available all the tools the how're
your user is using that data in data
studio yes so usually when you advertise
on different channels you wanna I wanna
see a combined view of how your
campaigns are performing so that's one
one one thing they can do cross-platform
view of their campaign performance they
can also merge their advertising data
with their sales data which is also an
interesting use case where they say okay
all right but doesn't cost is watts and
then we generate that this much revenue
based on their weights because and
you've also made a lot of templates
available for these view that people can
use with your connectors yes so what we
do when we create a connector we also
want to create a high quality template
to go with that connector so it's really
easy for users to get started so when
you start using any of our connectors
there's a pre-made template that is
populated with your data so you can
immediately see how how your data looks
like and based on that template you can
then start doing customizations and
modifying that to fit your particular
needs if an organization wants to make
their own data available to their
customers for the studio how can super
metrics help them in that area so if
there's no connector already available
for that particular data source there
are some options we have something
called a custom JSON CSV XML connector
so that you can use to get data from any
endpoint that provides data in one of
these three formats so chasin CSV or XML
and our connector takes that data and
processes into the format the data
studio expect
so it's really easy to get get that data
in today the studio start reporting this
straightaway that works in many cases
not all of cases so if if that doesn't
work for you the other option is to
contact us and we may be able to build
that connector for you for data studio
we've seen a lot of users and developers
who use it purely as a marketing
reporting tool but there are also other
users who are using it not just as a
marketing tool but also is a completely
full-fledged API reporting solution yeah
so what are your views on this yes so I
think right now it's still largely used
for marketing purposes and a large part
of the community connectors are also
marketing related data studio is a great
tool and it can be used for other
purposes as well and I think that's an
area where we are expanding to in the
future very very very strongly so we are
soon releasing our first financial
connector getting accounting data into
Data studio we are gonna follow up on
that with various other kinds of
connectors that are not marketing
related accounting finance HR customer
service all kinds of different choices
that can be visualized in data studio
how should small and medium businesses
approach their marketing reporting and
analytics dashboards keep it simple to
start with it is to get a bit carried
away with all the cool features that are
available in data studio you don't want
to want to create a cutter dashboard
with all the different chart types so I
would concentrate on a few key metrics
to start it make a really really simple
dashboard pick metrics that the audience
understands and that are actionable two
years ago we didn't really have a big
developer community around data studio
since then we've launched the community
connectors feature we're working on
coming visualizations and more and more
people are getting interested in
building tools and solutions around data
studio
so what would your advice to someone
who's just starting
build solutions around this tool I think
data studio is a great platform for
developers it's really easy to get
started the documentation is really good
and you've done
good job on that and also you get a lot
of support from from your team obviously
when you build a connector so getting
started with building connectors is
really simple and I definitely recommend
that the challenges may be then come a
bit later data studio has a large user
base in the millions so if your
connector really takes off you may get a
lot of users and that brings new
challenges that you then need to tackle
such as how do you handle the traffic
flows with rate limits that are in the
data source API that you connect to so
you don't go over any any limits that
are in the source API so you need to do
a lot of caching in different places to
tackle that you need to have monitoring
in place you need to be able to handle
all kinds of edge cases with the queries
such as what if your query takes over a
minute to run when the timeout for HTTP
requests is one minute so all kind of
things like this in it then start
thinking about what to get started it's
really easy because thanks again for
being on the show thanks was quite being
here you can check out the super wedges
connectors in the data studio gallery
link is in the description below make
sure to subscribe to the GCP youtube
channel and you can always visit our
website at developers.google.com slash
data studio until next time keep
building morbus
[Applause]